- I'm a right handed person.
- But for the next 24 hours.
- I'm going to be a lefty.
(energetic dance music)
I am so reliant on my right hand
and my right foot that I don't know what
I'm gonna do when I can't use them
as my dominant side.
- For minor tasks like opening doors,
brushing my teeth I'm fairly confident
I can use my left hand pretty well.
But anything that requires accuracy
or dexterity that's where
I think I'm gonna struggle.
- I already suck at doing
makeup with my right hand.
My eyeliner takes me like 30 minutes
because I'm so bad at making it match.
So using my left hand
I'm going to have to
wake up two hours early.
That's gonna suck (laughs).
- I'm excited for the challenge
although I am positive
it's gonna be awful.
- So I'm gonna write with my left hand.
I don't even know how to
hold my pencil (laughs).
Okay I have no strength
in my fingers right now.
I am not proud of myself.
This is bad.
- I'm not proud that it
looks like a two year old
wrote this sentence (laughs).
- I don't even know where
to start crossing a T here.
Oh god (laughs).
I'm proud that it's legible.
I think you can tell what I wrote
but I also thinkit looks horrendous.
(frantic rock music)
- Now the hard part is the eyeliner.
- No makeup except the mascara
put on with my left hand.
I hope I'm not blinded after this.
- Oh my god (laughs).
It looks crazy.
Second try.
This is not working this is hard.
- I did it they're not totally even
but they're sisters not twins
just like my eyebrows.
- I don't think it's bad actually.
I think I look like
my every other day it just took way longer
than it should have.
- So I bought this new mouse
that's a bit more ergonomic but I realize
the way it's shaped is for
right-handed people only
and using that for awhile
was pretty challenging.
- Very slow process (sighs)
This is going to take all day.
Which part do I have to click on the mouse
even the left and right
click are so confusing.
- Oh my god.
I'm not even kidding I
can't do it (laughs).
- Is it really that hard?
- I'm actually trying my
best right now (laughs).
- Here comes the nightmare of my evening,
So far not so bad.
I don't think I'm doing a good job
but I'm not cutting myself which is great
also this razor is probably
like 100 years old.
My leg is feeling a little bit like
I might have cut it a little.
So gonna go check that out.
(tranquil techno music)
- After being a lefty
for a full day I realized
that my left arm is significantly
weaker than my right.
- This was a good experience.
I'm gonna go back to using
my right hand now though.
- The lesson here is I need to
one exercise more cause I
just don't do that anyway.
And two maybe experiment with a few
things ever day or week or month
with my left side keep it relevant.